we bring in Albert brear from the Monday
Morning Quarterback Albert
it sounds like doom and gloom here for
New England is this the is this the last
roundup for the Patriots as we know it
well first of all I appreciate the
gambling talk I give you guys a quick
gambling story you want it by degenerate
days one of the babies I ever did was I
build Madden we used to put it on I love
the computer play and bet on that late
at night so III really enjoyed hearing
those stories coming in yeah you know I
do think that um
you know I think when you look at it
there's there's there's definitely a
sense in that building that major change
is coming after this year and that the
team is going to look significantly
different last year I figure and then
you know I think it said that that opens
up very real questions about you know
who could be coming and who could be
going in addition to the moves that
they'll be making on their own you know
and so what those five players that are
wearing the quarter seem right now for a
tea Gilmore according Gronkowski and
Hightower all five of those guys are
going to be 29 or older next year and
now if they were all to be on the team
next year there are no account for more
than 40% of your salary cap you know
generally the way to make up for that is
by having you know promising young
talent of rookie contracts and they
really don't have that either now you
know and so there's very very serious
question out there how he's going to
make up for you know a couple of that
dress and and how you're going to manage
the A's on your roster and so I think at
the end of the year it's southern Josh
McDaniels going to look at what do you
think the decision start what he wants
to do
Brian floor is that the linebackers
coach is a factor coordinator he could
be another guy who potentially could be
on the move you know and then the big
one of course is the quarterback and you
know how does Tom Brady you look at it
going into a season in which would be 42
years old with a team that could look
significantly different there are big
questions there are no question about it
okay who do you think will
be on the team next year let's start
with Brady's Brady playing next year in
your PIN I said right now I think so I
thought I don't think that's a hundred
percent I know I like like it like
anything now you know I had together
nice two months ago
no effect you know how he thinks about
this I would say that I I think he'll
play next year but there are moving
parts there and so one of the moving
parts is his contracts are they going to
be willing to extend him past 2019 and
that's an open question what's got a
team around him going to look like are
they going to go into a 2019 was Tony
nettle Minh and Rob Gronkowski those are
open questions and are they going to be
more aggressive and pursuing pursuing
veteran receivers
yeah I just think that there are a lot
of holding parts there and and I think
at the end of the year their feet up
it's a long season and how do they feel
about the season that just went down you
know how do they feel physically going
forward I just I I think it's something
that that that on a year-to-year basis
when you're that age you know it's
basically on precedent what he's doing
you've got to consider so I don't I
think it's in tension right now at the
play it's in 2019 but just my belief is
there's just so many moving parts there
that it's hard to say anything with
complete certainty yeah and then I
wonder about Gronk I just like he just
looks like he's Herman Munster trying to
run down the field he just he doesn't
look comfortable doesn't look healthy I
know he had a touchdown reception but
Edelman looks not average but he doesn't
look he's not explosive the way once was
you got Hogan in there I think you know
Gordon has been good but I don't know if
he's there for the long haul with the
Browns then you look at the defense you
know they don't there's no who's there
impactful defensive player there who's
the guy that you go that's who we rely
on or we build around and and they just
don't have that so it feels like they're
vulnerable even though they're gonna be
one of the top seeds in the playoffs
yeah and I think that when this team has
been in trouble in the past that's when
they become over
reliant on Brady and ballot set and look
those guys are great I mean there's
there's no question that both of them
are going to be in Canton and you know I
think she make you know very real
arguments that got the best coach of all
time and the best player of all time
there and I think on a pretty consistent
basis they're going to click it 11 or 12
once a year without even considering
what's around them
I think what's bitten them in the
playoffs in the past is when they've had
teams that have been over to and that's
sort of like what this is if you watch
the gaming of the Jets on Sunday
everything looked hard right
everything was hard yeah and it didn't
really break out til the end of the game
and so much of it was dependent on Kim
Brady put the ball on the tight in a
tight spot across Jim Brady put the ball
in a tight spot to Edelman can they do
anything to loosen the Jets up and then
on defense like you said there aren't a
lot of difference makers so I think
Belichick is a guy who becomes the
difference maker there are they too
reliant on Brady to make it work on
offense and Belichick to make it work on
defense I think that's the question you
got to ask going forward it's hard to
bet against them in January and February
based on the track record but I don't
think that this is a team that it was in
2016 I don't think was the team that it
was in 2014 and it's certainly not the
team that they you know had 10-15 years
ago when you had all those all those
names on defense and so it's definitely
a different dynamic there you know and
again I just you know I think you look
at the team now and your team struggling
a little bit to find itself and then you
think of the challenges ahead 2019 and
you know it certainly looks like this
could be their last best shot
good stuff Albert we appreciate your
time thanks for joining us that's Albert
brear the mmq b.com for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
you
[Music]